de Marsella burdeos pasando por la
ciudad noroccidental de morle por décimo
cuarta vez en cinco meses los franceses
salieron a la calle para decir no al
plan de reforma de las pensiones del
gobierno la participación ha bajado pero
los manifestantes están más decididos
que nunca lo principal es que aunque no
reunamos a tanta gente como en el pasado
las personas que están hoy aquí están
convencidas lo que también hay que tener
en cuenta es que no podemos pedir a todo
el mundo que pueda ir a la huelga
siempre porque somos muy conscientes de
los problemas de poder adquisitivo de
hoy en día una historia similar en las
calles de París la población francesa
sigue poniéndose mayoritariamente al
aumento de la edad de jubilación a 64
años pero ahora que la reforma se ha
convertido en ley parece que el Gobierno
ya ha ganado la batalla los diputados de
la oposición tienen la intención de
celebrar una votación este jueves para
conseguir que se derogue la legislación
una medida que la mayoría dice que
impedirá
en ningún otro país democrático se
aprueba por la fuerza una reforma a
pesar que casi toda la población y todos
los sindicatos Están en contra a pesar
de protestas sin precedentes de los
últimos seis meses es un asunto grave y
demuestra que tenemos un problema
democrático e institucional en Francia
Emmanuel macron dice que la revisión de
las pensiones es esencial para mantener
el sistema fuera de los números rojos
ante la proximidad de las vacaciones de
verano y la moderación de la inflación
el jefe de estado Espera que la opinión
pública cambie de postura pero los
críticos dicen que mantendrán la